well we recently told you the pretty
remarkable story of a young man called
Carson King from Iowa King raised a
million dollars for charity for
Children's Hospital and the Des Moines
Register the local newspaper rewarded
him by digging into his personal history
all the way back to high school
denouncing him for tweets he made seven
years ago for this he was pilloried and
has a bush which had agreed to a
partnership with him dropped him now in
a fascinating coda to the story Aaron
Calvin that's the reporter who wrote the
original story has been fired himself
after he was found to have offensive
tweets on his Twitter timeline as well
amazing you know who still though at the
Des Moines Register Carole hunter she's
the editor who made the call to publish
the piece and to crush Carson King she
appears to be completely fine and to be
clear we're not calling for a firing we
think it's a little bit weird that the
kid gets fired and the person who makes
a decision gets to stay is that fair
Joao Concha writes about media for the
hill he joins us tonight Joe is that
fair no it is not fair this isn't some
rogue reporter Tucker that just writes a
story and there goes out published there
is a vetting system and the vetting
system starts with the senior editor
that you just mentioned she has a job
tonight and by the way she only put out
a statement an op-ed basically
explaining what happened and we hear
about news organizations publications
demanding transparency from people and
power that they cover I agree with that
completely but in this case she should
be answering questions right now in
terms of why she okayed it and why this
reporter was thrown under the bus
because he very easily Tucker could have
been on order saying why do you look
into a social media history and look as
a writer as a reporter myself if an
editor tells you to do something you do
it and when you submit a story the
editor could either pull that out or
keep it in but either way ultimately it
shouldn't be completely your
responsibility while the editors get
away with zero responsibility well that
does seem right I mean her justification
and by the way she's basically
illiterate I mean for a newspaper
reporter or editor she can barely write
you know in English maybe it's not her
first language mine
but in her explanation she said we we
wanted to perform a background check on
this subject I'm just some kid who was
giving money to a charity there's no
need for a background check but we're
gonna do a background check they didn't
do a background check on their own hire
how does that work exactly it what do
you need a background check by the way
it's completely irrelevant to the story
he raised more than 1.7 million dollars
and yeah I mean I think we have to start
doing that now and as a matter of fact
Tucker I think the educational system
starting at the high school level and
even junior high should start and I I'm
completely 100% serious about this in
their curriculum a course that says you
know what social media behavior and
consequences because guess what
employers are doing now they used to
hire companies to do background checks
they don't do that anymore they check
your social media feeds your Twitter
your Instagram your Facebook one
inappropriate tweet or Facebook post or
picture and that can alter your career
path and I don't think enough kids 16
years old in the place of Carson King
when he put up those tweets or even this
writer Erin Calvin I don't think anybody
understands at that age that anything
you put up into the public record is
gonna have consequences no question
about it by the way the reporter is
speaking out tonight from the Des Moines
Register who was fired and you're not
gonna believe what he said you're not
gonna feel quite as sorry for him he
tells BuzzFeed Tucker and I quote this
whole campaign was taken up by
right-wing ideologues and largely driven
by that force adding it was just a taste
of what I assume that women and
journalists of color suffer all the time
I mean are you kidding me
he's making himself a victim he's a
victim as the editor threw him under the
bus but to say that I mean it's hard to
feel sorry for him at this point Tucker
it's sad I mean who goes into the
newspaper business now that we're not
we're not sending our best into the
newspaper business as Trump would say
unfortunately I used to work in a
newspaper but it's it's true
unfortunately Joe great to see you
tonight thank you it's a dying breed
unfortunately it is Thank You Tucker
every good weekend